the world is in the midst of an economic
downturn certainly a global recession is
a major risk three of our biggest
economic engines are sputtering from war
in Europe to a lockdown China and Rising
inflation a bitter blend is hitting the
world's economic powerhouses
and there is no no no no sort of point
of light at the end of the tunnel here
because it all now begins to feed on
each other
in this video we will be asking what
makes this economic downturn so
different from the Great Recession in
2008. this is a recession that is unlike
perhaps the financial crisis recession
that was due to finish crisis that is
being felt but every single individual
definitely for the years to come we are
going to witness a world from a Chinese
perspective that we are not accustomed
to
we will discover the paradoxes that make
this downturn unique so the labor market
actually looks quite good which is one
of the confusing things about today's
economy we will assess how easily this
crisis can be remedied compared to the
last we don't have tools at the moment
that could address the recession that
we're facing and we will look at the
countries who are bucking the negative
Trend that's all coming up on business
Beyond
both the IMF and the World Bank are
warning that we are edging towards
Global recession but determining what
counts as a recession and what doesn't
can be complicated
there is no official definition a common
rule of thumb is that when an economy
experiences two consecutive quarters of
negative growth it's in recession
but a decline in GDP isn't the only
indicator other metrics like
unemployment levels and consumer
confidence also play a role people lose
their jobs they have to cut into their
savings unemployment can be extremely
disruptive personally not just for
economic reasons but for one sense of
well-being
for a recession to happen many factors
are at play that's why declaring a
recession is often in the hands of
national organizations that analyze
business Cycles
like National recessions Global ones
also don't have a clear-cut definition
they happen when a large number of major
economies are going through an economic
slump
in our globalized economy a recession in
one place spells trouble for another
knock-on effects reverberate throughout
the globe
and that's what has analysts worried
right now certainly a global recession
is a major risk but our current forecast
has what we would call a growth
recession we do not have a contraction
in the global economy but we have subpar
growth with Rising unemployment
GDP growth in the global economy is
slowing down the international monetary
fund predicts that a third of the world
economy will likely be in a technical
recession next year the US and Eurozone
are facing an especially gloomy Outlook
in the U.S economic growth is declining
to a fifth of its 2021 levels next year
in the Eurozone growth is almost
completely stalling
for many of us the phrase Global
recession still conjures up images of
publicly shamed bankers and people
losing their houses to understand the
current economic downturn better it's
worth revisiting what happened in 2008
during the financial crisis
pushed the world's banking system
towards the edge of collapse and left
borers no longer able to afford their
homes
and it all started with a housing bubble
in the U.S a whole industry ballooned
around giving people mortgages
mortgage brokers eventually got greedy
they started giving out loans to people
that didn't make enough money to pay
them back those mortgages were combined
into big packages and sold to Banks
ultimately the inevitable happened
borrowers couldn't pay their loans back
and the House of Cards collapsed causing
a banking crisis
the first recession was a recession that
was essentially one that was built on
fear of Banks and mistrust people that
were in Banks because they weren't sure
anymore which of the banks was solvent
and which one wasn't so they stopped
Landing all together Banks had to be
rescued from roon by government bailouts
and the crisis spread beyond the United
States European Banks had bought a lot
of Bad Mortgages from the US so they
also collapsed and had to be bailed out
by governments
many European countries eventually could
no longer pay their own debt government
budgets were squeezed resulting in years
of austerity and dramatically impacting
the lives of millions of Europeans
so how is the current economic downturn
different this time around money isn't
the issue
there is no Capital shortage in fact if
anything Banks and the cap the the the
capital markets are sitting on loads of
money that at the moment they can't
really spend because there is nothing
that comes into the EU economy so this
time the world isn't short of cash but
it's sort of almost everything else when
the pandemic struck the fragility of
Supply chains became apparent factories
from Asia to Europe and North America
halted production
sending the global economy into a free
fall
as countries emerged from lockdowns
demand for goods and services returned
faster than Supply now swelling orders
have outstripped availability businesses
across the economy have struggled to
hire workers
food and energy prices are on the rise
adding to that the world's manufacturing
Powerhouse has closed shop in China
lockdowns continue to wreak havoc
chienping's zero covet policy aims to
isolate every individual case of covet
19. a strict implementation means
regular shutdowns make business and
Manufacturing extremely difficult
when they get waves you know entire
cities are shut down and that affects
the supply chain throughout the world
now shortages of one thing have turned
into shortages of another a scarcity of
semiconductors has halted car
manufacturing
and unlike during the us-led financial
crisis it's Europe that feels unique
pressure now
with the world Supply chains and trouble
are ready one added Factor made for the
perfect storm on the continent the war
in Ukraine
[Music]
which woke us up to the realization that
Europe is
relying on is for one of the most
important inputs for its production
namely energy on a very very unreliable
partner
for decades Russia was Europe's main
provider of gas delivering almost half
of the Block's gas supply but that's
drastically changed this year as Europe
has rushed to find alternative energy
sources Europe needs to reduce energy
Demand by 10 percent
that already means that we will get into
an economy that produces uh produces
much less but it's not just energy
that's become a casualty of the war
Ukraine is one of the biggest
agricultural exporters in the world
since the Russian invasion food prices
are on the rise for the European and for
the global economy supply shortages and
a drastic rise in food and energy costs
make for a toxic cocktail if the demands
stay the same and the supply of a good
falls in the price Rises if you have
that across the economy as a whole in
the labor market in many Goods markets
in energy markets and in Food Markets
then you have a generalized inflation
for the first time
the world is facing an inflation crisis
the U.S the United Kingdom and the
Eurozone are especially feeling the
price surge
in the EU inflation is the highest it
has ever been in the US it's at a
40-year high
inflation
is a major challenge for all of us
around the world too much money is
chasing too few goods that means items
we need for our day-to-day lives are
getting more expensive it's also what
makes this economic downturn so
different from the last
this is a recession that is unlike
perhaps the financial crisis recession
that was due to finish crisis uh that is
being felt but every single individual
simply because all of us have to use
energy at home and and all of us
understand that when inflation is high
with the pregnancy power of our salaries
or of our income and of our wealth
reduces
the cost of living crisis confronting
the world is now causing a shift in
global economic policy making Central
Bankers say they've had enough of Rapid
price Rises we took today's decision and
expect to raise interest rates further
because inflation remains far too high
and is likely to stay above our Target
for an extended period we have both the
tools that we need and the resolve it
will take to restore price stability on
behalf of American families and
businesses
price stability is the responsibility of
the Federal Reserve and serves as the
Bedrock of our economy
and the U.S reduced a
boost to encourage Banks to start
lending and help economies weather the
storm this time they're flipping the
script
for every Central Bank that is currently
cutting interest rates there are now 25
that are raising them according to
Deutsche Bank a ratio that hasn't been
seen in decades
by making it more expensive to buy a car
get a mortgage or use a credit card they
hope to reduce people's spending and
slow inflation but the tools that will
fix Rising prices also stall economic
growth
it means that we have two problems and
we have both low growth and high prices
and therefore the policy makes then is
to address this crisis needs to be quite
different and also the policy mix is a
little bit more Awkward if you like in
terms of meeting the two problems
central banks are facing a difficult
Balancing Act raising interest rates
could further sink a rudderless economy
doing nothing means letting inflation
run loose
there's several real questions that
we'll determine how the next year plays
out
first how effective are central banks in
reducing the inflation without sending
the economy into you know worse
recession that would be required it's
very difficult to get monetary policy
just right because there are substantial
lags in the system right so what's
perfect for today
policy wise we often can't tell until
six months down the road and something
else feels different about this economic
downturn especially in the world's
biggest economy the United States for
many people the word recession means
worrying about losing your job that's
because the two usually go hand in hand
in the U.S GDP went down in 2008 and
unemployment went up this July the
country's unemployment rate was the
lowest it has been in half a century and
it has stayed exceptionally low since
despite an economic downturn
so the labor market actually looks quite
good which is one of the confusing
things about today's economy you have
some indicators that look very positive
and and
consistently so and you have some
indicators that are far more worrisome
but the the labor market indicator in
the U.S in particular is very strong
unemployment is quite low labor force
participation is good
job openings are high relative to the
number of people seeking jobs so this is
a time of enormous labor market
opportunity and strength for a lot of
American workers
this is a unique time in the U.S
companies can't afford to lose employees
because many of them are having problems
finding workers in the first place
but the US is facing a paradox despite a
strong job market people are worried
especially those looking to start their
careers
current class of 2023 is certainly
worried about the current economic
situation so about 50 percent of our
respondents from one of our most recent
surveys shared that they absolutely have
some concerns and anxiety
[Music]
things are looking good and gloomy at
the same time and that is making
Americans feel uneasy
sumer's sentiment is a measure that
shows how people feel about the economy
and whether they will spend or save
their money right now people are only
feeling slightly more optimistic than
during the 2008 recession
and what does that mean for the future
of the US economy the job numbers are
looking much Rosier than during the last
economic downturn but how people feel is
a core driver of economic growth and a
pessimistic Outlook can turn into a
self-fulfilling prophecy
a very different economy but one which
is also going through a turbulent period
is the world's second largest China
Decades of surging growth have seen
China dramatically catch up with the U.S
economy in terms of size but policy
makers in Beijing are now grappling with
a multi-faceted economic crisis
the pandemic and the real estate bubble
have combined to take a hammer to
something which China had come to take
for granted economic growth
China's annual GDP growth has steadily
declined over the past decade somewhat
inevitable given how Hyde has been
before the pandemic the country was
still recording growth of around seven
percent but following a bounce back in
2021 the IMF now expects the Chinese
economy to grow by just three percent in
2022
what we have been witnessing for the
past nine months roughly is a continuous
slowdown of the growth dynamic in China
during the 2008 financial crisis China
introduced a huge fiscal stimulus
package many analysts created this as
the reason China weathered and recovered
from that storm much quicker than other
major economies if you look at the
2008-2009 recession the Chinese fiscal
response was quite
um strong like they did a good job
keeping the Chinese economy going
despite that recession and that was
helpful to the world economy as a whole
if Chinese growth helped the global
economy out of the last crisis it's
unlikely to do so this time around
China's zero covert policy and the
Draconian rules that accompany it are a
big reason
that largely send a message to Chinese
consumers and investors that now in
China
politic trumps everything when politics
would come as a as a hindrance for
economic growth
the Chinese Communist Party would would
make the right call and and let economy
Prevail what zero covet has notified is
that that perception is if not wrong at
least no longer viable
um in in in XI jinping's China zero
covet has dampened Chinese economic
sentiment and sapped domestic
consumption Chinese consumer spending is
more than 10 percent less than it was
before the pandemic
another major factor driving China's
problems is its housing market
China's property sector has been in
crisis since 2020. new government
regulations on debt aimed at Cooling and
overheated real estate market saw
companies like evergrant run out of cash
soaring property debt has been described
as a systemic risk for the entire
economy and since the Crisis began
China's housing market has experienced a
severe downturn
between zero covid and the real estate
crisis China has enough problems of its
own to contend with and that's having a
knock-on effect around the world
if China is not buying that means that
Europe is not selling
so I think there is there is there is an
element of sort of bad news if you like
coming also from the Chinese economy
slowing down so what does this all mean
for China and the world economy as a
whole well the Chinese economy is still
growing not Contracting but a Slowdown
has already begun and it may be part of
a longer term shift
there was this almost unbreakable
feeling that the Chinese leadership or
the Chinese Communist Party put it as
you wanted would guarantee
that their children or a decade to come
will be richer than the decade that has
just passed and indeed that was rooted
in almost five Decades of astonishing
economic success
nowadays
it seems that
the Chinese households understand that
the growth driver that they've
experienced for the past decade has run
out of fuel
and that the Chinese leadership in
Beijing is ambitioning to redirect the
economy towards a new form of
equilibrium
it appears that the engine which helped
jump start the world out of the last
Global recession won't be up to the task
this time around it's clear that the
world's biggest economies are facing a
storm but one area of the world has been
bucking the trend
during the 2008 crisis China was still
outpacing its Asian neighbors now for
the first time since 1990 other Asian
countries are set to outperform China
economically growth is still outpacing
inflation here I would have never
thought right I think it's it's just the
difference in Cycles because uh Asia
asean and India you know they were they
were really buffeted by our first The
Wave in 2020 then the Delta Delta wave
in in 2021 but thankfully not So Much by
Omicron and you know they are coming out
of their lockdowns for most of this year
as China went into a lockdown uh this
year because of the zero covered uh
approach so just you know it's still
very much Kobe Centric that that
difference and in terms of their demand
emerging economies are benefiting as
China's zero covert policy is worrying
investors
if China goes into lockdown where is
your alternate production base in Asia
you know should you be moving to an
Indonesia
in the Asia Pacific Indonesia has been
thriving especially Against All Odds
economic growth has been outperforming
forecasts here and inflation is still
slightly under six percent the cost of
living crisis is crashing down on Europe
and the us but in Indonesia government
fuel subsidies have softened the blow
the Indonesian government is setting its
own prices for gas so-called
administered prices
Indonesia is definitely benefited from a
lot of policy support so the reason
inflation is so low is because it's
administered price there
and you've and because that has kept
that low the central bank has not been
under so much pressure too high
the subsidies have amounted to a hefty
bill for Indonesia's government and
might not be sustainable in the future
at the same time Rising commodity prices
around the world have actually helped
this economy Indonesia's coal exporters
are bringing in record earnings the
country is looking at a promising 2023
so at 4.7 I would still say that growth
Outlook is is looking pretty resilient
uh next year especially you know when we
talk about our major economies entering
recession at the beginning of this video
we looked back on the recession of 2008
and we asked how this economic downturn
will be different what the experts we
spoke to described was a crisis not
triggered by Banks but when partially
set off by War and by politics are there
some things that are inevitable like
standing up for democracy as the
Europeans and as Ukraine and as the
United States are trying to do right now
I think you know the cost of that
um is not zero right and but some things
are worth paying a cost for
um
of course governments should do whatever
they can to cushion their citizens from
these costs but I don't think telling
citizens that the cost is zero is is
realistic or true and there are some
things in life that are you know worth
making a sacrifice for with bank
bailouts and regulation policy makers
have the tools to react to the financial
crisis but much of what's happening
right now is outside of policy makers
control the mechanisms to address the
supply side crisis are you know nothing
more than invade China and force them to
produce semiconductors invade Russia
enforce Putin to to to to to stop
invading Ukraine and and loosen energy
superbly and so on and that's obviously
not going to happen so we don't really
have tools in the normal State of
Affairs we don't have tools at the
moment that could address the recession
that we're facing while central banks
intervene to stimulate the economy in
2008 they are adding to a downturn this
time the medicine against Rising prices
is also poison for the economy and
unlike the 2008 financial crisis this
downturn is having a much more obvious
impact on our daily routines everybody
understands that we cannot switch on the
heating at the coming winter as much as
we did in other years or we are going to
see an exorbitant Bill everybody who has
a car will have seen it in the run-up to
the uh to today to the financial in the
run-up to the energy crisis how petrol
was so expensive in filling up the car
so this is a crisis that I think
dissipates across everybody in the
society and therefore it's much more
felt it's not just about the economic
impact the households feel it you you
feel it immediately in your uh in your
household income but there are also
positive developments that run opposite
to the financial crisis we are in a
moment where there is great talent
shortage and so even if we do go into a
recession there's still a lot lots of
jobs that are available that are out
there we are at a unique inflection
point in the global economy compared to
the last crisis the one we are facing
now is much more multi-faceted war in
Ukraine an energy crisis soaring living
costs and widespread pessimism are
combining into an unpredictable economic
concoction
and that's all from this business beyond
episode if you enjoyed it please hit
like And subscribe and check out one of
our other videos until next time and
take care
foreign